he also wins  both in this round and the next round he  will also be on 21 points but the bar is  over to do that side in that game and if  he loses it's over for nardisky these  are the current standings a few games  have finished Bunch still going on and  we do see a niche on 19 about to go up  to 20 points needed 18 David Anton  losing it's over for him he will uh he's  stuck now on 16 points but Vincent Karma  and naroditsky on 15 still fighting for  points in this round  and I think we're going to see a draw  any moment the player's repeating moves  do we have a result there there we go  Anish might feel like he got away with  one yeah shaking his head he is  definitely aware that this does not  secure his Plot In The Knockout stage he  needs point in the final round as well  and in that final round who will  anishikiri play